what I'd like a I to be I'd like it to
be a technology that enables everyone
and that is built for us it's built for
people my parents should be able to use
it and environmental scientists should
be able to use it and make new
discoveries or a policymaker in order to
take good decisions you're listening to
the Microsoft Research podcast a show
that brings you closer to the cutting
edge of technology research and the
scientists behind it I'm your host
Gretchen using up with all the buzz
surrounding AI it can be tempting to
envision it as a standalone entity that
optimizes for accuracy and displaces
human capabilities but dr. Bess
Marunouchi a senior researcher in the
adaptive systems and interaction group
at Microsoft Research envisions AI as a
cooperative entity that enhances human
capabilities and optimizes for team
performance on today's podcast
dr. new she talks about what it takes to
develop collaborative AI systems and
unpacks the unique challenges machine
learning engineers face in their version
of the software development cycle she
also reveals why understanding the
terrain of failure can help researchers
develop AI systems that perform as well
in the real world as they do in the lab
that and much more on this episode of
the Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
best Mira knew she welcome to the
podcast thank you it's great to be here
I've been following the podcast in the
last year and you know it's always
interesting every new episode is
different you've been following the
podcast that's enough well I've talked
to you before last time you were on a
research and focused panel at faculty
summit in 2017 and you talked about ml
troubleshooting in real-time systems
let's go there again as a senior
researcher in the adaptive systems and
interaction group you work at what you
call the intersection of human and
machine intelligence yes so we'll get to
your specific work in a minute but in
broad strokes what's going on at that
intersection what gets you up in the
morning well the intersection is it's a
rich field and it really goes both ways
it goes into the direction of how can we
build systems that learn from human
feedback and input and intervention and
maybe learn from the way people solve
problems and understand the world and it
also goes in the other direction in like
how can we augment the human
capabilities by using artificial
intelligence systems how can we make
them more productive at work and putting
the best of both worlds together let's
talk a little bit more about this human
AI collaboration you framed it in terms
of complementarity because humans and
machines have different strengths and
weaknesses and you've also characterized
it as putting humans and machines
together to quote-unquote optimize for
team performance yeah elaborate on that
for us how should we understand AI as
collaborator versus AI designed to work
on its own you know people and
algorithms they have very different
skills we're really good in reasoning
and imagination and machines are good in
processing these terabytes of data for
us and giving us these patterns however
you know if we can use the Machine
capabilities in an efficient way we can
be quicker and faster as
said but then on the other hand you know
these are concepts that if you think
deep about it they are not that new in
the sense that when we invented personal
computing in the 80s this is one of the
reasons why it became so successful
because the personal computer was
suddenly this body that could help you
do things faster and quicker but then
there is another thing that enabled that
development in those years and really I
think that that is the field of
human-computer interaction yeah what HCI
did in those years is that it made the
interface understandable from a human
perspective and it really made
computation technology accessible for
everybody so now we see billions of
people around the world that use some
form of computation without making any
significant effort right and I think
that today we are in front of such forms
of developments in artificial
intelligence we are in a way in the
position that we can innovate in the way
how people interact with AI technologies
but we still need to make that leap and
make AI accessible for users right and
this is what I mean by the fact that so
far we have been optimizing AI for
performance only and performance when
the AI is designed to play alone in the
field but if it has to play together
with a human there are other scores that
we need to think about for example one
of them is interpretability
in that people should be able to
understand how a machine makes a
prediction
another one that we focus a lot on is
predictability of errors and what this
really means is that if I'm working with
an AI algorithm I should be able to kind
of understand then that AI algorithm is
going to make mistakes and this is
important for me as a user because if I
have the agency to make the final
decision at the end I need to know when
it's right or wrong so that I can
correct it at the right time as it goes
let's drill on on the topic of AI is
collaborator done
we've talked a little bit about AI
working alone and it's designed to
optimize for performance and speed how
do you then go about training ml models
with collaborative properties in mind
instead of optimizing for speed and
performance what are the trade-offs in
the algorithmic design and how do you go
about enforcing them all right right
yeah so you read that it is always a
trade-off it is a trade-off for the
machine learning developer to decide
which model to deploy should I deploy a
model that is fully accurate by its own
or a model that optimizes team
performance but the difficulty is that
this trade-off is not always as feasible
or as easy to access so I see the work
that we do in our group as in enabling
paradigm that allows you to explore this
trade-off or in a way to extend it and
show it to the developer so that the
developer can make the right choices and
there are two ways how you can go about
this the first one is what happens
during grid search
so in machine learning we call grid
search this process where you try to
search through many many many parameters
and through this search you try to find
the model that pleases you the most in
that it is accurate but what we suggest
is that you should also be looking at
this other scores that work for
collaboration like predictability of
errors so the second way you can go
about this is to include these
definitions in the training objective
itself and we have been doing more and
more work in this part because we think
that this explores the trade of even
more it extends it it gives you a rich
perspective of how many other parameters
you can optimize and augment the
objective function in a way that it
should think about accuracy but it
should also think with a certain factor
about this human collaboration
scores and the best way to go is to do
both during training and during grid
search so that you really get the
algorithm that works best for humans so
you've talked a bit about enforcing
properties within the algorithmic design
yeah unpack that a little bit more yeah
so the enforcement
comes from the optimization stage during
optimization in machine learning we
model a loss function and this loss
function is the function that gives a
signal to the training algorithm on how
well it is doing whether it is a good
model or it is a bad model and this is
really the only signal that we get and
this computation on the data right so
we're saying that signal should be
augmented with these human collaboration
scores and be put together so that when
we train the algorithm these properties
can okay first the other way you could
do it is by adding constraints in the
training algorithm saying that whatever
you do whatever model you find you
shouldn't be going lower or upper than a
particular score
[Music]
well let's turn our attention to the
methodologies and tools you're working
on for machine learning systems and
before we get specific I'd like you to
give us a general overview of the
software development cycle writ large
talking about the differences between
traditional software development and
software engineering for ML systems yeah
so machine learning has really been
until recently a research like field in
that the algorithms were in the lab and
they were accessed by the machine
learning scientists but now that we have
machine learning deployed out there in
the field in different products machine
learning software is being combined with
traditional software however these two
are very different in nature together in
that machine learning software can be
undetermined istic it may be hard for
you to say what it is going to do and it
also may have a black box nature in that
it's hard to understand what exactly it
is going to say and also it may make
these types of mistakes that do not
happen because of bugs in the code it
may just be because the data that you
are training the algorithm upon might
either be insufficient in that there is
not enough to learn what you want to
learn or it may not quite resemble what
is out there in the real world it is
just lab data and it's never going to be
as rich as the world that we'll live in
and also needless to say in this is a
very subtle difference but we often
forget about it is that in machine
learning we don't really write the code
that is going to execute the program we
write the algorithm that is going to
process the data and come up with a
function that is the actual code so all
these differences make the process very
very different
it is very data dependent and in
traditional software engineering for
example we didn't have these parts of
the lifecycle that we currently care so
much about that for example data
collection and data cleaning if it has
mistakes in fact like according to a
study that we recently did and Microsoft
collection and cleaning takes at least
50% of the time from machine learning
yeah and you know this is significant
yeah it's a lot of time that is spent in
to these new stages yeah the other thing
is versioning so in traditional software
we know very well how to do versioning
we have tools like github another
versioning tools that do that for us
but in machine learning we have to
version not only code we have to version
the model we have to version the data
and the parameters of the model so there
are all these things that are entangled
together and that we need to version in
the right way okay so let's go a little
deeper there you've got your traditional
software engineer that is very
comfortable with how this all works and
now you've got machine learning
engineers that are adding on layer upon
layer to this software development cycle
how are you addressing that so far what
we have done is we've started with first
understanding the needs of machine
learning engineers like and
understanding their background as well
you know because machine learning
engineers they may come from different
fields some of them may not have a
computer science background they may be
data scientists they may be
statisticians right and the practices
that are used in statistics and computer
science may be very very different
within the same team you may have people
with so many different backgrounds and
you need to put them together to speak
the same language right so we started by
trying to understand what is their
background and what are their problems
and the first number one you know
challenge that they have is to have
end-to-end support in tooling that can
support all these different stages in
the life cycle it will take some time
but I think we're getting closer have
you laid out the stages as they were I
mean the software development cycle is
very precise yeah and the machine
learning what bigger it is so we have
defined a few stages and there's other
work that have tried to do the same
thing we have stages like data
collection they are cleaning model
training feature engineering
and then model monitoring and debugging
and maintenance so these are kind of the
main stages if I didn't forget any of
them but what is different there is
something that is very interesting in
the difference between the two is that
the machine learning life cycle is very
experimental in that it is a little bit
of trial and error in a way this grid
search that I mentioned earlier it's a
little bit of trial and error you have
to try different things to see whether
it works for your domain maybe you clean
the data once more maybe you add some
more features or a different
representation so there is a lot of
experimentation and when there is a lot
of experimentation there is a lot of
uncertainty you don't know as an
engineer whether it's going to work or
not so it has changed even the way we
plan and manage projects well let's go a
little deeper and talk about that
troubleshooting and debugging that
you're working on it's a key challenge
for all software systems but it's
particularly challenging for debugging a
black box yeah and especially for
complex mission and safety critical
software and hardware which you're
dealing with all the time in the real
world so how do you go about let's get
real how do you go about designing
methodologies for the debugging phase in
the ml development cycle yeah it's a
topic that is really timely in that you
know if this is deployed in places that
are high stake like in medicine or
autonomous driving this can really have
like either a very good impact or very
bad impact someone or flying or fine
yeah it can have a you know different
impact on people's life one of the
things that we say in our work is that
good debugging practices start from
rigorous evaluation you know how many
times we hear things such as this model
is 90% accurate on a particular
benchmark and we use that one single
score to describe the whole performance
of one algorithm on the whole data set
often that single number may hide so
many important conditions of failure
that we don't know
and that are so important to know if you
are an engineer what we suggest is that
that performance numbers should be
sliced down into different demographics
and different groups in the data so that
we really understand is there any pocket
in the data that is maybe
underrepresented and maybe the error
rate is higher right so these are the
things that we suggest to do and then we
also continue and build interpretable
models in order to explain exactly to
the engineer when and how does a machine
learning model fail and we often suggest
to do this for different groups I'll
just give you a simple example we
recently were looking at general
recognition software from image photos
and we noticed that when these models
are trained only from celebrity data
they have a much higher error rate for
women that have short hair that do not
have any eye makeup on and also do not
smile in the photo it's complicated it
is all these different dimensions that
are put together and the process of
finding this particular thing for
example I would have never thought to go
and look for it but this is what the
interpretative model gives to you and
you know it takes away a lot of load
from the engineer if you can at least
automate part of this process so how are
you automating parts of the process yeah
so what we're doing is that we're really
gathering this data together and we are
asking engineers not only to store the
final aggregate number of performance
but we are asking them to give us the
performance numbers on each example and
at that point you become super powerful
in that you can put in an interpretable
model that can slice and dice the data
in the right way and can show you
visualizations about where these pockets
of errors happen well and it also comes
back to what data is available what data
you have access to what data people are
allowing you to use because there's a
trade-off right there you want fully
accurate and representative models but
celebrities are out in the public domain
and a lot of people just say I don't
want my picture in anybody's dataset and
therefore you're precluding some of the
important nuances that you might need in
your data to get accurate models so
there is a tension between you know
being ethical about collecting your data
and being accurate in the data I think
as a community and also as an industry
we need to think deep about how to
standardize this process well as we've
just kind of laid out it's hard out
there for a machine learning engineer
these people need a whole new tool belt
for the job how is your research in
adaptive systems helping to equip them
with the tools they need for an AI world
these methodologies that I just
mentioned in the last two years we have
worked hard with many people at MSR AI
but also in Microsoft cognition to build
concrete tools that can automate part of
this process and the tool that we are
building now it's called error terrain
analysis and it really helps in
understanding the terrain of failure
this is an effort that I'm leading
together with Ajay Kumar and a lot of
people from the ethics and society team
that cares a lot about these types of
problems in the company and broader than
that and really what we were doing with
the tool is that we are building
workflow of processes and modular
visualizations that can be put together
like LEGO pieces so that you can go from
one general view of errors to a more
detailed one and even more detailed one
in looking at particular instances let
me ask you one question on that because
we talked i'm harkening back to our
conversation at faculty summit yeah and
we talked about how modularity is good
both in software development and for
understanding how things work but it
also can have problems in the debugging
because you have these different modules
that aren't all connected and if
something goes wrong with one or
something is better in one and you've
got an older module it poses new
problems yeah it does in this case we're
thinking about these modules more as
visualization models in that first you
want to have a large overview of the
data and this would be like one module
and
you want to drill down into the other
ones so that you do not get overwhelmed
as an engineer so that it is not too
much information for you okay yeah go
back to a phrase you just used the
terrain of failure mm-hmm unpack that
for me it's very intriguing yeah so what
do we mean by the terrain of failure is
that if you think about it like you know
as a set of mountains and hills and
seaside there are cases when you know
the terrain of failure is really calm in
parts of the data in that the examples
are easy to classify there is nothing
special about them and everything is
flat and there are other cases where the
data is so rich there is so much
diversity in the data in like your
demographics or other properties where
the error can fluctuate a lot and we
want to feel the terrain and to really
understand what it looks like yeah
that's one of the most evocative phrases
I've heard what other kinds of tools do
ml engineers need that are being worked
on sort of upstream in the research
community I'd like to mention a set of
other tools that we are also building in
the group one of them is called
interpret ml and this is work that is
led by rich Caruana in the adaptive
systems and interaction group they are
really building a toolset for building
interpretable models and generating
explanations from these models yet
another tool is called this is shiny new
it's called tensor watch and this is
built by Sheetal Shah who built this
tool for doing real-time debugging so
that you can see the errors and the
training laws of machine learning models
on the fly that said I think that there
is still a lot to do when it comes to
stitching all this together into one
single framework and as I said we need
to do end-to-end framework in versioning
in data provenance data documentation
and in tools that can allow us to take
these insights that we get from
troubleshooting and debugging and
integrating them back into the system
for fixing them and I will not claim
that
is going to be automated but at least
there is like a workflow and process if
that happens well at this point I'll
take good over automated well hype
notwithstanding AI is still highly
dependent on people and I'm not sure
that's a bad thing I think that might be
a good thing
why does ml add a difficult layer to
this idea of self-healing software
that's one of the things you talked
about at faculty summit where one
component fixes another based on
feedback and how can strong causal
reasoning tools and counterfactual
analysis tools help us better understand
what went wrong yeah it is hard to heal
a machine learning software but it is
even harder to heal a system that has
many many machine learning components
that are tied together and there isn't
why that is difficult is because
sometimes it is hard to understand the
different dynamics and interactions
between the components we've done this
work that I also talked during the
faculty summit on generating
counterfactuals in the sub components in
order to understand how these
differences in the sub components affect
the larger systems and again we are
using human intervention to generate
these counterfactuals for us
so that we can understand the dynamics
better the belief that day is starting a
new stream line of work in the space in
order to optimize large systems that are
integrative and to optimize them on the
fly in real time so this is something
new that is happening in over although
you know the good news about causal
reasoning in these systems for debugging
particularly is that as opposed to other
fields like for example in medicine we
can actually run the system again if we
want to apply